one of the first problems critter
junction had to solve was package
delivery
once they made a change of code how
would it get deployed to users in a
scalable fashion
let's look at how critter junction
implemented a gated tag-based ci cd
pipeline
[Music]
when critter junction was just a
prototype funneling up their app and
sharing it with the
testing team was fairly simple the
coders could just email a link to the
application running on their dev
machines
but as the application and its
development team grew that was no longer
feasible
manually testing and applying changes to
the code base became a bottleneck for
the team
without a reliable mostly automatic
process to build test and update their
micro service based application
critter junction just wasn't going to be
able to scale to the level they dreamed
of
so they implemented a ci cd pipeline
using cloud build
google's serverless ci cd platform and
spinnaker an
open source continuous delivery platform
this allowed them to rapidly iterate and
test the code base
the high level steps of this pipeline
are as follows
a developer changes code and pushes it
to a repository
cloud build detects the changes builds a
docker image tests the image
and pushes the image to artifact
registry
spinnaker detects that image deploys it
to a staging environment and tests the
deployment
after all tests have passed the release
manager can manually approve the build
and deploys the image to production
let's look at each of these steps first
the team was already using git to manage
their source code
as is common in game dev they store
binary assets elsewhere
and pull those in when a build occurs
using git allows devs to check out a new
branch of the code base to do their work
in before merging it back to the main
branch
after it's tested this lets developers
easily work with other developers
and gives you a lot of flexibility in
your workflow
critter junction took advantage of git
tags to create a ci cd pipeline that
kicks off whenever a new tag is pushed
into the git repository
they use cloud build to produce
application binary and set up a trigger
to watch for any commits with a git tag
prefix with the letter v in addition to
commits with a specific tag
triggers can look for commits on a
branch or pull request
it then automatically starts to build
and tests the new docker image and
pushes it to artifact registry
which is a single place for your
organization to manage container images
and language packages check out our new
series on artifact registry
in the link below and the final leg of
the process is kicked off once spinnaker
detects the new image and artifact
registry
from there spinnaker will deploy the
image into a scaled down staging
environment for integration testing
these preliminary tests allow critter
junction have the best chance at
minimizing
failures once those tests pass a build
engineer is allowed to flip a bit and
push the new image out to production
where critter junction's audience can
access the new feature
between git cloud build artifact
registry and spinnaker
critter junction was able to develop an
automatic gated
tag-based continuous integration and
deployment pipeline that allowed for
faster iterations more flexibility
and reliability for their containerized
environment
this pipeline allowed critter junction
to smoothly scale up and quickly add new
features as their game gained more
audience
and acclaim check out the link below to
learn more and thanks for joining us for
season three of season of scale on
microservices
statelessness and continuous delivery
stay tuned for what's next for critter
junction and remember
always the architect
[Music]
you